okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about the handling of
historical entities in wolf language so
examples of that are well let's take a
look here we are dealing with the Roman
Empire for example so okay so what is
this so this is now what on earth is
this -27 thing doing oh that's a list of
years and polygons so when one query for
the Roman Empire and the polygon and the
date is said to all it shows a list of
pairs when where the first element is a
date and the second one is the polygon
that we have for that span of years okay
so is this is this working now yes
that's working now okay so so one of the
issues here is going to be I mean what
should this return should this return a
time series or what should this return
because I think this list of pairs is
crazy I mean I think if we're gonna do
that we should and this date arrow all
it's the wrong thing as well right but
this is what's happening right now is
that right but what I think should
happen is that we should be doing
essentially Roman Empire and that's
presumably going to be historical
country that that is the same thing
there that input form right okay so then
what we think we want to do is something
like if I'm not mistaken well I don't
know you tell me
I mean we could say dated 55 BC or
something
that is by the way weird that 55 BC
turns into that I mean that it displays
like that is kind of weird what do
people think about that I mean if I say
you know August first
you know 917 77 or something
Wow why is it turning into I thought it
would turn into oh I see it it formats
like that but it turns into that do we
think that's right Nick
I mean there in general I think the the
name Lou has for what's in control
equals is mostly input form there are
special cases like quantity the typeset
there but I think the idea is that you
want to be able to see what the the
language representation of it looks like
without necessarily typesetting
everything we could certainly make an
exception for dates I think we should
consider that let's put that put that on
the shelf for a minute okay yep but now
this thing here this is not going to do
anything right now
no but what you can do there is that you
can try to add some properties like for
dated Roman Empire in that year and you
can add a polygon and you can get a
result on this case well the Roman
Empire was not in that year so we can
try something like 55 AC what 35 so plus
55 you're saying oh yes well the reason
- fortified in work is because the Roman
Empire as such did not exist it was
something with a different name is that
right yes that was the Roman Republic
yeah thank you because Caesar didn't
whatever whoever made okay so this is
one of the many many cans of worms that
we're going to deal with here is the
concept of the fact that we want a
generic I mean okay is this continuity
of things because the fact that it was
the Roman Republic as opposed to the
Roman Empire is going to be kind of
subtle
okay I you know okay so then this is
alright by the way why oh that's the
polygon of this which is again a kind of
an obscure thing I'm not sure
most
I see but but because most things like
geo so if I say Geo graphics of this or
am I gonna get okay fine I get that um
okay so if I'm but mostly what we want
to do is be able to feed in and I don't
think that's gonna work right now if I
take this dated Roman Empire thing and I
just say geo list plot of that is it
going to work
No so that should work I think do we
agree
correct okay fine okay so go ahead what
should he do
because in PC but it's just a single
object well cheerless plot works fine
for a single object I see I see
oops oh my daughter corrected why it's
taking so I have no idea why is it
taking any time there we go okay so
that's what that should do um and uh
okay so in other words dated of Roman
Empire fine
now take this plot map geo area so if
I'm to say so so why wouldn't this work
so so then presumably geo area of so I
mean if I say let's just check this if I
say geo area of control equals Roman
Empire
okay that works fine so then the only
issue is to do it with with the dated
rapper as well it's alright
yes yep and and the the meaning of the
dated rapper is is it an entity
qualifier or what does it look like
underneath underneath the hood yeah it's
a it's a qualifier for the editing
property I believe yes it's it's hurt by
the property not by an entity so okay so
which is not obviously correct so I mean
we have this notion of an entity
qualifier which is something like you
know five grams of gold for example
right yeah I think that's entity
instances yes instance yeah but that's
that's because something underlying that
and the Alpha frameworks courts that
kind of thing that's that's not a model
that applies to every other kind of
entity but in terms of design
shouldn't
okay is the Roman Empire in 55 ad an
instance of the Roman Empire
well here look look look look we've got
in fact the exact example look at that
yeah what do you know I'm sorry this is
not gonna be winnable look at this
that's an entity instance which is
equivalent to saying I think dated
Ireland okay so wait a minute what I
just dated want something else
Oh deja I'm sorry it needs a date I'll
just fundamentally going to distribute
the those other qualifiers across the
properties
you
so you think this to okay this thing you
want to represent it in language but I'm
just saying under underneath what yeah
that's fine what it does underneath is
fine but I think we need to support
entity instance um of you know so we
need this notion of a qualified a
historically a date qualified entity
instance which I think this is fine and
it's equivalent to dated awful thing and
this is yet again equivalent to oops
island dated you know so if I say
Ireland and then I say dated population
eighteen fifty or something then I'll
get a results great Wow it's interesting
it's higher in 1850 than in 1950 is that
because it broke off that I'm afraid is
probably one of these contrary
continuity things because probably
Northern Ireland broke off right history
buffs
but it didn't change the name of the
core thing it was still called Ireland
yes in particular in country data we
have been more let's say flexible in the
population property so that we are not
breaking that exactly when it started
but some kind of continue it yep so that
I can have all populations okay let's
take a look at the area of the Roman
Empire here okay do we believe this plot
curtiss this plot what do we think is
happening when it was I mean like this
is very unlikely to be right
well that gap was the first time of the
division of the Roman Empire between
east and west and I think that was with
Constantine I think and then it got
Merrigan and then it go in what it won
don't know this one here I understand
but what I'm saying is look at that
straight line joining what's happening
in 300 AD with what's happening in 340
ID maybe it should be a step but really
know that I think because what we have
are they will have intermediate points
in this case OS which thing that's a
pure profit problem right but so the
question is what happens if you say okay
so what happens if I say geo area of the
dated Roman Empire right so let's say I
say dated Roman Empire of um and I want
it for 320 AD
see whatever you call it plus 320 right
so I don't know whether this is gonna
even evaluate okay so it gives a value
but now what happens if I say 330
okay so it's gonna be the same up until
I see so the way this is working is
so I understand why that function
oh there was an all there but so if I
were to plot so I couldn't principle do
this um but I could if I really wanted
to live dangerous I could say plot but
let me let me just do this table geo
area X goes from let's say 280 to 3:30
and steps of 10
by the way Nick how is this going to be
all that was decently fast okay so what
we're seeing here is that it it jumps
and steps right is that is that the best
we can do so far from more sources we
have our area we have polygons for each
different date in that case so we only
have that kind of step increase in the
all change on the polygons but what do
we think so so in cases like those blips
what are those blips those may be cases
where for instance the Romans conquered
a province and then they lost it like
the next year the highest accuracy we
can get when our sources is like one per
year accuracy in that regard okay so did
that happen a lot today did they like
gains it so if I look I don't know what
if I look for example let's do the
corresponding thing for it's like
Germany around the time of the Second
World War
now I'm gonna show my pathetic knowledge
of history um when did it start when
when did they walk into an Austria 1935
or something
[Music]
Angelus wasn't 38:38 francisco and
company is this gonna work with Germany
or not because the thing is that well
it's not a historical country so what do
i what do I do to get the historical
country of Germany we can put Nazi
Germany in the in the case as historic
on three I see okay so this is something
again we're going to have to resolve
what what to do with this you know that
this is this question about whether
that's interesting that's bizarre
okay that's off it's frigging weird how
could it have a negative area that's
that's coming from these error messages
because it's field curve and and feel
curve not necessarily has the first one
outer the other one you know in this
case it got confused for some reason so
you're saying what happened is within
the territory controlled by Nazi Germany
there was a whole and we didn't handle
so so are we doing version 12 hold Polly
goalie polygons for the for all this
historical country data or did that not
yet get done not yet
so the idea is that we have now the
protocol was with holes and then we will
propagate it to you by the way does
anybody know whether I have an area
where I'm keeping notes about this stuff
okay I'm gonna start a new folder called
historical data I wish I could say that
I think this is gonna be done in one
meeting but I don't think it will be um
we can't
after all summarize all of history in
one meeting okay so if I were to do this
so for example here if I say
so here like like if I'm saying um like
1940 here what you think okay but if I
say gee oh oh I see if I say polygon of
that you think I'm gonna get some
bonkers thing okay and if I say
cheerless plot of that what the heck is
that well that's really weird because
it's lines
I see it's a filled curve of lines but
then those lines are doing something
wacky you trade your graphics energy
instead of just what oh yeah okay it's
not even right but the oh I see that
that's Poland that's modern Poland with
a piece missing is that right that's
correct and a piece missing was taken by
uh Soviet Union was attacked on the East
from the other country lovely mm-hmm
okay but but so where's the where's the
missing whole I mean in in some so
somewhere in the middle of this there's
some problem with with topology right
there pretty quickly I see I see so okay
so this is great so that I mean this has
okay so you think it's a small hole of
some kind it might be the water on the
border on the border between Poland and
Germany you see there is yeah close to
the Baltic Sea so maybe that's how does
understand that as a whole what's a
water body there yeah well okay so
there's a whole polygons with holes okay
so question have we done have we re done
all of these historical countries as
polygons with holes I think because
Geographics does not yet support the
polygons with holes so now that we now
that we have them they will
for the next question okay alright so so
basically we think it's non stupid to
basically just go yeah yeah yeah
constant constant constant until we know
something changes I agree with you I
think that's us non stupid as we can be
so in the case of this what we should do
is simply when we give the examples we
should give stat plots do we have a date
step let's plot I think so really
necklace doesn't appear to have been
cash or to be cashable or is this some
silly query does it look like a
particularly silly query yeah
sometimes things are tricky with
qualified properties but I would expect
this one to be cashed well just look
into that okay yeah um so you're saying
we think there is a date step let's plot
or not yes we have a date at least step
trot okay fine great okay so that I just
think when we give examples we should
use that so people don't get the idea
you can do this
okay time series polygons time series um
so right now this instructor of date
comma the polygon it's like the one that
it's expected by daily splode and
functions like that
sorry further again so which is this
structure because that's the one
supported by a list a lot of functions
for example so it's a it's not a slice
it yes right right right right right
right so that's a different I see I see
so the issue is what do you return when
there's an interval right
what do you return for an interval what
do you return in particular in the case
of the complete okay so we've got an
analogy you know word frequency data has
this analogy you know um
[Music]
let's see we've got time series here
right that right that will give us the
the complete time series of that use of
that word now what you're saying here is
what's the our log for getting the
complete time series of the polygons
that right now we just do to return the
date comma value because I don't think
that's great I think but it's a question
of what you're returning it for I mean
if you this case this syntax is
sufficiently complicated I don't think
that's what we want people to use what
we want is for them to be able to
generate a you know the analog of this
dated all also works so that's probably
do these pass
okay so women so you're saying
in this case here I'm not gonna do this
probably because if I were to say dated
comma all here polygon right then I
would return give me something which is
a smaller Empire well who knows
okay so then this case is gonna return
this form here this this okay so I claim
this should return a time series
time series or an event series we really
have a different construct here because
we have something which is a a a time
series in which you're stepping you get
what I'm saying or is that or is can
that be represented by a time series in
which the interpolation is what it is
it's called from the left so that's what
I would suggest because you know that
the polygon is constant for you know
some years til it's changes to something
else
so you just called right okay so fine so
there's a there's a representation in
the time series wrapper that allows us
to specify this so let's convert this to
a time series so how would we do that so
if I just say time series of this okay
hold on let's let's just do it to see
what we are getting okay so this is all
um okay so time series of this and then
how do we do the whole from left so dude
a sampling method the sampling result
would be something because there's
meaning accessing that and then in the
string hold from the left and hold from
work from left hold from left yes mmhmm
like this oh we can pick a different
thing than whatever okay there were only
eight data points here eight years oh oh
right right um oh it's the changes it's
not by year it's quite a time when
something changing the polygon when you
look back at the least their first date
is 46th and 8th one is you know it's
never a fifteen 48 or 49 so if you do
the right I see I see I see I see so
nothing happened okay I get it
um I mean one day we might want to try
and be more precise with these although
you know at some level right you're not
gonna get the second at which something
happened
um okay but you know we in fact have any
more precise data of um I mean clearly
okay by year most military campaigns
it's like it got somewhere during that
year whereas if we try to do it by the
by the even you know by the day it's
like you know tanks were rolling but
they had you know who knows how far they
had got if I'm making sense of them but
okay so here
fused wide oh I see those are that's the
time series format okay so now if I want
to extract something from that time
series what would I do if I say percent
25 and then I say of 1938 does that work
date object you know but like so I can't
say that no it has to be recognizable as
a date in the system why do we make it
great because the data at a time series
it's not stored properly in an old book
it seems not to be right because that
isn't going to be an adequate answer
yeah see that does the right thing but
this needs to do the right thing
this needs to give us so it's wait a
minute so you're saying you gave us the
wrong specification or you think that
this is I mean this should work is that
correct yeah I think I thought what
happened thing is that I gave you the
wrong string which I would like to check
because the other way I know how to do
it the other way but it's longer so it's
just by the way when are we going to get
this is a this is a comment for anybody
involved documentation here when out
which maybe is nobody when are we going
to get the the raft coming up for
options that whose whose project
managing here can we
that's me Fatima but I think I think
that's yeah that's for Brian or Ben but
the basic point is that the raft of the
same kind that comes up here
should come up for these options to go
what I'm saying yes okay anyway what is
the what is the correct name oh sure and
you can we can we do it can we say it
differently so or something method goes
to open a open a list and put
interpolation comma interpolation as a
string comma interpolation order goes to
zero I didn't like oh well that's
because percent was something stupid
twenty-four okay so then thirty-eight so
what we should be able to do here then
oh come on
Oh percent 31 okay so what we should be
able to do just naively here we should
be able to say yeah and then we can go
from what did I have nineteen thirty six
so I can say table yeah
1936 to 1940 what did i do nineteen well
1945 there but if you gotta have said 47
didn't I okay so let's see what this
does
so this should be generating and it's a
bit slow oh come now
what is that
the problem here is that we have values
for the entity until 1945
that's where Nazi Germany ceased to be
so the thing is we're looking at the
time series beyond it's the main so the
time series defined exists on 18 1945
right and then you ask for the
extrapolation so it's gonna continue you
know interpolation which is
extrapolation but it warns you that you
went outside of that that input value
thing is really pretty nutso I don't
think okay listen we should clean this
up a bit because we're going to be using
this for for these I mean we don't want
to talk about interpolating functions
because they shouldn't because there
really isn't but it's a zeroth order
interpolation that's gonna be confusing
to people etc okay but also we need a
way to to say before this date and after
this date return missing because that's
something I think the time series should
do in this case for some yes I got it
right that's right go show you
understand what being said there no but
that means that you as a defining that
would put as the you know next value you
know after you're given value foot
missing because from the from my point
of view is you know like I just get an
object I don't know that the the values
after that should be missing it's no
issue so you can but when you put
missing in you put music at the end of
your data then everything after that
will be extrapolated as missing because
it holds the value from the left so okay
so one way to touch if that will be to
put in the end date the missing value
mm-hmm but then also the fingers yes
and what's return when using calls from
left for the left side when I'm thinking
just need to probably again introduce
the starting value which is the missing
right before your first volume okay
because I wonder if it will be easier to
have another option in time series to
allowed to have some kind of valid
interval if that makes sense having this
cut off adding the ending data's so you
would want to have like the domain in a
way yes that makes some sense I mean
it'll probably even make sense for an
interpolating function actually
something like it might be interpolation
domain or some such other thing I don't
know what what the right name for it is
but I would suggest that that's relevant
for everything that interpolates
everything when interpolation order okay
let's continue so that's one one thing
we're dealing with here okay so then the
proposal is that dated all but now what
happens okay so what how do we get a a
time series a dated interval a time
series for an interval of dates so we've
got dated all but so let's imagine that
we want this one where I want to say you
know dated and then I want an interval
here can I do that does that work no we
are supporting there I love States yet
okay so probably we should but but Nick
is there a different way you want to do
this yeah okay so that should probably
work
yeah I mean there there's a larger
discussion about date intervals in a
language and how we want to design them
and you know the the two main sticking
point right sticking points which aren't
as applicable here are opened and closed
end points which we don't have a
universal design for an interval to
begin with I know we're gonna have to
deal with that for dates I understand
that although a state so fuzzy enough it
doesn't really matter
yeah and then you know there was a
question about whether it should be a
data interval or a date span because we
may have some interest in in the
sampling frequency of it which you know
how that relates to granularity is a
little different of you know I want you
know resolution on a year basis but
maybe I want it on a daily basis but my
sampling frequency may be different all
right okay so one piece of this then is
how does data to take intervals and then
what granularity of sampling is there in
the interval right now I mean arguably
dated could just take I mean as a
syntactic hack dated could perfectly
well just take the naked into you know
the naked list here because dated itself
normally you know it's only taking an
integer as a courtesy
right normally it would take data
objects yeah and as a reference that
interval will work if you change those
to date objects I think the the server
right now doesn't know how to handle so
the line above that in 36 if you change
that to data object of 1935 then it
would then this will actually work yeah
I believe we it works with some domains
I'm not sure about historical country
okay um
okay not working with this record
country I already so that that's the
syntax it's used in some other places
for specifying a date interval inside
dated okay all right but that's
something we're gonna we need to deal
with yeah um okay
and I I suggest that for a historical
country stuff that we support things
like this
I think dated in general is you know for
the stuff for the for the types of data
that we have so far
dated is year granularity type stuff and
I think we can perfectly well support
those things but you will need to add a
double list isn't it why because if not
that could be confused with a 1935 with
blonds month 1941 no but I don't think
that's right Chris doesn't dated require
date object in general right now data
does not support a date list
specification right I don't think it
should I know the kitchen I think it
should either be a date object or a year
because so much of the time you're just
going to be doing it by year um I have
some comments on the live stream here oh
the potato famine I forgot the Irish
potato famine that's why the population
went down in 1840 late 1840s um Karl is
complaining about the lack of a date
round accomodate interval function
what is this tape round that seems like
a Knick issue yeah we have day round
which isn't general to dates and we have
next date in previous state but we don't
necessarily think is just a hole that we
can have it yeah yeah we have the
functionality to do it right because day
round is specific to business day stuff
and it was introduced for financial data
kinds of things yeah and there's a whole
there's de rounding Convention arguments
for de round which times time but this
is this is going to deal with that the
the century so this is but in general if
I want to take the year you know the
Year 1830 or something and I want to
make that the 19th century don't I just
say date object what do I do here do I
say date of the century yeah and it will
go to the closing yeah it will go to the
in closing right yeah that's right so
other way did you fix did you fix that
stuff that came up in it for the
interpreter for 18th century and so on
did somebody fix that we just didn't
have if you type in interpreter Rea date
18th century it's not working perfectly
well work and go to a century garudadri
date mm-hmm yeah I think it's it's
trying the wrong person path but I'll
check on that um okay Karl is asking
about Lesotho as a whole polygon with
holes it's being fixed that's what
that's what polygons with holes the new
polygons with holes will deal with that
Ethan is asking about he's asking for a
lot he's asking for entity value for
glaciers to have time series
sorry don't have that um is that it what
what is that actually what is the status
of that I mean Alan do you happen to
remember we don't we don't have that
data there's a there's a database that
has a lot of sort of statistical data
about Quakers but they we have never had
polygons for the the boundaries the
extent of them okay fair enough we are
currently working on a new geo server
protocol that will know about dates so
we will be able to connect these
databases or dear servers like NASA for
something which has which has time
series based [ __ ] polygonal data is
what you're saying for time data so to
access this time time it time data right
and what are we doing by the way with
geo image I assume geo image is gonna
get some some geo image it's going to be
able to do dated type stuff
right as soon as we are current data
source if I'm not mistaken is some um so
if I say geo image Eiffel Tower for
example right now that's just gonna give
me the current Eiffel Tower all right
but if if we have historical imagery
then we should be able to get that is
very why did why did it pick that
rearrange it's the default geo range of
about demise I think I see yes don't you
think that for a syrup I mean if the Geo
range if I said something like um for a
point object like a building that does
seem a bit odd to have to go as far as
10 miles yes it's it's different now for
geo positions for points like objects
right but that might make sense for geo
list plot it might make less sense for
geo image but if I said here um just to
understand if I said here geo range is
like 200
feet that will just work right yep
should do at least um okay
I don't know updating you know what the
heck is going on that's nice and maybe
the Eiffel Tower is being repainted a
different color and we've got yeah do
you see that those the planet labs guys
just launched another like 80 satellites
last week this may be independent its
tongue goes in because that simple
attitude you should I bought here yeah
okay yeah one question which is being
raised by what Ethan is asking on the
livestream is what do we do with an
object where we don't in fact have a
time series but where somebody says
dated of whatever what do we say do we
give a message we probably should see
what I'm saying so in particular with
the glacier example if you say dated I
mean you know we obviously have geo
positions of glaciers but even those
might be completely wrong
well whatever I mean but if somebody
asks for a dated thing and the dated
thing doesn't exist same deal as with um
the you know Nazi Germany 1948 right
doesn't exist we should be saying that
we should be generating a message that
says it doesn't exist all Roman Empire
in 55 BC type thing or whatever it was
am I making sense but in that case we
could answer with missing not applicable
and maybe with a second argument there
or some of these rappers that could tell
you that
which carol was
the answered a question on the live
stream about geo imagery is yeah we
intend to work with all possible
providers of such um just
all these things take time um okay ah
okay let's see so so I'm sorry we're
back to so in the case of geo image what
we expect to be doing is just saying do
image updated or whatever to get date
specifications is that right yes so the
idea is to have um mmm
a general language inside the Geo server
option and then shortcuts of that form
okay let me ask this question if I say
dated of this comma 1930 clearly geo
position could ingest that date yes it's
good something but should it I don't
think it should exactly it's nothing so
anything eating that object should
understand it but it's what is what are
you with elevation data which is what
are you doing there is that that has
another wrapper right for around reopen
that gives the elevation is that true
yes so the idea was to have a function
that would shift is your position yet
okay fine but that will then that will
then put the elevation into the Geo
position yes has already and a date yeah
I know it does I know the default date
is right now is the default date now or
is the default date any the default
elevation is serum with respect to the
ellipsoid and the default time is now
okay is it obvious that the default time
should be now rather than any basically
well why hmm what's gonna use that value
I see if you feed it to it like a
satellite data thing it's going to use
the value of time but it could I mean
that's another case where we're going to
have so satellite data also generates a
time series right so satellite data
travel direction type stuff and your and
the aircraft paths will generate time
series right we also have the de
Hemisphere and this type of thing
needing time right but so so if I do
this and then I say what do i what do I
just say here location or position
position okay so that's the current
position so then this should work
presumably with with either dated of ISS
or dated a position does that work I
don't think this works
well actually it appears to work that's
great why it gets extra precision on the
time I have no idea I think this is now
I don't know let's see if we if we think
it's plausible I mean if we do that and
then we say why is it doing that now has
extra precision its microseconds and
because this is in seconds from 1900 its
1900 it's it's a huge number so if I say
so this should just work geo position
percent for car percent five cool that's
pretty cool that's so that's the
distance that's the actual distance
traveled by the space station right
because assuming a straight line
assuming it wasn't yeah it's actually a
curved arc because it's got all three
XYZ coordinates um okay good question
from Karl on the livestream are there
hooks for data to work with custom
entity stores anybody know there are I
mean dated basically boils down to a
reference to the date qualifier for any
given property so I don't have a easy
example offhand but I've seen Tony
demonstrate using dated so like the the
same interface that's used for the
market data links the bloomberg and
Reuters uses the same dated reference or
it uses data to refer to those objects
which are created via custom entity
stores okay I I see I understand so the
Bloomberg link if you say dated of some
company it'll do the right thing yeah
okay so oh boy we got a lot of stuff to
go over here um okay
what is this until Earth magic doesn't
work with dates we know this this is
being worked on by Nick right yep yeah
part of the temporal logic thing and so
on right and it'll probably have a
different head than interval but
interval of a date will give you a date
interval in whatever form we have that
right okay the next big issue okay so I
think we're okay with all of these
things the next biggest who is
historical well look there's two
problems one is this whole entity
continuity for countries and the other
is this thing we're about to look at
which is what is this
the Geo lookup question what the heck is
this here
what is this so in this case we're
looking checking the polygons for
historical countries that we have on the
year 3000 BC so we're looking that we
can work you can use data as well on the
on the well I see on type our on the
property Wow I see so what you're saying
is and why are you saying delete missing
here because most of what happens is
that there are countries but they were
so for example if I say the most naive
thing would be if I say well I don't
even know how to do this if I say entity
value dated - 3000 how would I do that
how would I get the entity list you get
what I'm asking oh we can just do
anything valuable country dated polygon
and then it's going to list all the
story polygons I know but I want it
without the polygons I just want the
names of the countries so if I say
entity or something here I think you
know the one entity class of historical
country and then to treat it as a that
looks like a big mess there
um let's ask the question so I'm just
trying to look syntactically if I want
an entity list of countries um the um
ones that existed in a particular time
yes yes we have any any syntax to do
that okay for that right now that's one
of the things we need to figure out fair
enough so I mean one way to do that
would be to say entity list I mean the
question is whether we're going to wind
up with a special wrapper for historical
countries I mean so we could do entity
list of dated historical country it's a
slight abuse of notation comma minus
2000 or something which would then give
us a list of historical countries then
possibly so we have internally some
classes
helper classes to to do this lookup also
but we never found the tactile syntax to
expose that so that's an example of
possible syntax for these classes Flair
enough well that would be a reasonable
thing to do someone with an
unpronounceable name on the live stream
is is pointing out the dynamic of JIRA
position of the ISS does the wrong thing
I'm not surprised I think if you do a
refresh
if you don't explicit refresh you can do
it but we are not triggering we don't
have the desire or the technology to
automatically trigger on a certain
distance move by a satellite so you have
to explicitly do a dynamic with a
refresh um Steven what if you did a
dated name instead of entity because if
the data is on the property name is a
property of the entity and we had dated
polygon oh but that's but that's because
what is I think if I do a delete missing
here I might actually see Mesopotamia or
whatever okay so so let's take a look
here wide almost and what these are
historical but okay so that's that
lookup but double dated country
extension year of historical countries
existing in the Oh minus 200 okay but
the thing that I'm okay geo within cue
this is the one I'm interested in it's
like what was here
okay hold on let's let's do geo geo what
is it Jill what am I looking for Geo
it's the thing that tells me Jill
identify so what was here
you know X number of
you know hundreds of years ago is my
question so geo identify and what I'm
asking then is entity type historical
country and then what I might want to
say is location so let's say but bababa
Eiffel Tower why not
okay so what's that gonna do okay so
that what we could do for this is to
give a time series
am i making sense
I I don't think so because so the idea
here is to return a list of entities but
maybe if we want a tank series we should
have a way to specify that we want that
explicitly I mean like for example
having a date date a circle country
comma all okay but then geo identify
historical country what would you like
to return you just a list of what
historical countries have ever been at
this location at any point of their
history you say I think that will make
more sense in the first exclusion so
then you're saying comma time series
would give us the time series I I'm not
I'm not I don't have a problem with that
what else could we put in this document
well it's rather a list or time series
which is similar to what we get in word
frequency data and so on and and we have
if we want a particular date now I I
wonder if we should use the dated rapper
in this case instead of having that
argument I mean around the historical
country yeah I'd prefer that okay yeah
okay reasonable enough and then dated
all would do the same thing it's doing
in other places and give a time series
right in this case we can also specify
the date or the interval dates let's say
yeah okay that's the I by the way I'd
like to point out that returning true if
at least one polygon blubber blubber
laura's with them whatever you know just
as we're supporting temporal logic we're
about to UM to do you know the temporal
logic stuff we're gonna need spatial
logic stuff as well and I don't think we
have that I mean do we have from the
region stuff do we have that kind of
special logic is this you know because
it's kind of calm
I mean is this region fully contained
within this one does this region overlap
this one I think writer was working on
that type of thing there are there's
something called Alan algebra which can
which handles like nine different types
of relations touching containing
lobbying is everything okay sounds
relevant yeah and I think Roger was
working on under special version of that
for four regions and so on regions which
would then work for this as well when
not directly we are also trying to
establish a bridge between the G on the
regions functionality now now that we
have the polygons with holes which was
the main connection piece and so yeah
eventually it should work okay all right
so I'm gonna have to disappear a moment
here um the
how would one use this to show
Confederate versus Union States during
the Civil War well we've got two
historical countries presumably it's
that right let's see if we say if we say
u.s. Confederacy
Confederacy if I can spell it no what
the heck is that Oh
that's really weird oh because it that
you didn't take that you didn't take
that linguistic for the u.s. Confederacy
since the u.s. didn't really exist at
that time or something I did I don't
know what do I don't know that
linguistic should probably work um okay
so then then this should give so what we
should be able to give here
ah gosh so here if I say dated okay now
I'm gonna totally embarrass myself and
not even know a date within the time of
the Civil War
okay what about is that right I'm this
is super embarrassing but um since the
first 64 63 and 64 okay
good glad you guys know history um okay
so that should give
ah what happened right polygons so
that's the entity which determines
there's rearranged polygons around dated
polygons updated with your graphics
Deborah fixes it split should also work
yes should work but in the same way that
would have to say put it on a France
beautiful interesting really whatever um
history lessons I don't yeah okay
yes and is commenting that in our data
we shrink the boundaries of the US
during the Civil War what a mess
okay so this that is yet another example
of one of this continuity of countries
questions
I mean do we have a sensible answer to
this of I mean in other words you know
like me not knowing Roman Republic
versus Roman Empire or get what I'm
saying I mean in other words is there a
notion
I mean there's also a notion I think
this is why we wanted a double dated
because we wanted something like what
did exist in 1900 which was a
continuation of what existed in 1500
what do you mean by that so you mean you
mean the projection of the country so to
speak at this time projection of that
country what what counts as a single
country I mean if that somehow did a
successor or the property I think well
we will have maybe it's classes also for
for this kind of continuity because not
all the cases you you have that really
okay but wait a second so you're saying
at a given spatial point there is well
at a given spatial point there is a time
series of what country was there but
this question about what is the
successor country of a given country
does that mean something or not I mean
what on earth is the I mean look in
practice you know there's obviously
countries can split in two but there's
lots of apparatus of a country you know
I mean there's probably some reasonable
historical definition of successor
country which could be more than one
country as a successor and we probably
can have that graph well see this is
really complicated isn't it at the
moment when a country splits in two or
something
the claim would be it's like it's like
you know there's enough cytoplasm so to
speak of the country that you can
reasonably talk of a successor country
he says no really the Republic of China
right they want the successor of the of
the pre-revolutionary China if they if
they want right
the people who were the apparatus of
government somehow went to Taiwan is
what you're claiming surface of test
area no but so do you do we believe that
there is a meaningful historical piece
of data which is what was the continuity
of the apparatus of government so to
speak but that I I agree that the Taiwan
cases though is is a complicated one
they um and also there are countries
that changed their name the formal name
so other different countries like
Venezuela it's a very an eleven if
boiler and in this case we are still
keeping the same country because it's
also the same isocodes etcetera so so
right now they are not like changing
totally oh wait wait
in modern times obviously there are ISO
codes for countries but the word
isocodes in the case of the roman
republic so in modern times this is that
definition we it's a new country if it
gets a new ISO code that right right
we've been trying to follow that and
that's why we have gone south is on for
a new ISO code right III I think the
only casing country data doesn't have an
ISO code it's well gas ice to it which
West Bank and Gaza which are also
politically with a lot of issues so does
Kashmir have an ISO code or is it now
that's part of a country think okay but
so so then okay
okay so at the current time ISO codes
are sort of the definition we can use I
need to I need to get going actually
here um okay so you I still have not
understood your double dated business um
we're gonna have to continue this
another time this is this is you know
this is coming together I'm happy to say
um alright
to be continued sorry I have to go um
thanks everyone thanks people on
livestream also yeah